[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour ce
nouveau numéro du 78 tours sur tv
soixante dix huit rendez vous au cours
duquel nous voyageons à travers le
département des yvelines pour découvrir
ses richesses son patrimoine ses
activités aujourd'hui autour de cette
table matip de franco bonjour et nicolas
landry bonjour vous allez nous
accompagner pour cette demi heure
d'émission baptise nous parlons du salon
de l'agriculture qui approchent et il
débute le 26 février il se terminera le
6 mars paris expo et le département sera
bien représentée effectivement j'y vais
demain pour aller à la rencontre des
producteurs et des éleveurs des yvelines
où seraient présentes dès le premier
jour vous allez nous tease est un petit
peu les différents rendez-vous qui rompt
qui auront lieu et puis à découvrir sur
notre antenne ensuite votre reportage
avec les différents sites qui seront
présents sur place nicolas avec vous
nous parlerons de tout autre chose nous
irons découvrir mantes-la-ville pourquoi
montrent la ville de mantes la ville
ville départ du paris nice la course au
soleil s'élancera le 6 mars prochain
pour se rendre à nice comme chaque année
le paris-nice course cycliste et donc
nous vous montrerons un petit peu ce qui
vous pouvez découvrir dans cette commune
de de mantes la ville méconnue un peu à
côté de demandes la jolie
au cours de cette émission nous
testerons aussi un food trucks qui
propose des hamburgers avec des produits
locaux nous découvrirons à le musée
contemporain grataloup à chevreuse qui
va ouvrir ses portes prochainement mais
pour le moment focus sur le printemps de
la sculpture
[Musique]
le printemps de la sculpture se
déroulera les 26 27 et 28 mars prochains
dans les yvelines et dans les
hauts-de-seine dans les deux
départements des visites guidées des
visites virtuelles également pour en
parler jessica barc bonjour
du conseil départemental des yvelines
directrice de ce projet l'opération est
principalement piloté par le département
des hauts-de-seine mais les yvelines y
participent aussi pourquoi cette
coproduction en quelque sorte alors
c'est vrai que c'est une manifestation
qui historiquement est porté par le
département des hauts-de-seine qu'il
organise depuis 2019 avec la volonté de
mettre en avant les sculptures qui sont
installés sur des sites départementaux
que ce soit des musées que ce soit des
parts mais aussi des sites qui sont
partenaires donc depuis maintenant
quelques années le département a
organisé un réseau de sites partenaires
et qui va proposer des animations des
événements et le département des
yvelines a été très intéressé aussi pour
valoriser son patrimoine sculpturale sur
le territoire la sculpture dans l'espace
public aussi con quelques fois on passe
à côté et on s'en rend pas compte mais
il ya tout un travail d'artiste et toute
une histoire sur ces différentes oeuvres
cette richesse et est bien présente dans
le département des yvelines
c'est représentatif d'un département des
yvelines on a la chance d'avoir des 13
me cite que ce soit le musée
d'archéologie nationale qui va plutôt
présenter les choses donc pour deux de
la préhistoire la commanderie
d'elancourt qui va être davantage sur
l'art contemporain au musée
départemental momie downing on va voir
des parcours sculpturale plutôt en intel
en externe abondent dans le jardin du
musée il ya des visites virtuelles des
visites sur place il ya une carte aussi
sur via internet une application mobile
qui a été qui a été développé ça
s'adresse à tous les âges même les plus
jeunes âgées c'est vraiment la volonté
de cette manifestation lassé d'être
grand public et de toucher un public
familial notamment aussi les enfants on
a trois journées en fait de
manifestations comme vous l'avez dit
avec une journée qui est vraiment de les
réserver aux publics scolaires et aux
publics empêchés donc ça va être la
journée du vendredi et puis un week-end
donc grand public samedi et dimanche
vous pouvez retrouver les informations
sur les sites partenaires parfaits merci
beaucoup pour cette présentation de cet
événement qui se déroule donc à la fois
dans les yvelines et dans les
hauts-de-seine et puis je renvoie vers
le site internet un printemps de la
sculpture points aux tirs et de tirer
seine.fr vous retrouverez abbatu leur
enseignement et puis cette application
aussi pour faire même peut-être vous
même le parcours à travers les deux
départements merci beaucoup jessica barc
d'avoir été avec nous pour évoquer cet
événement va rester dans la dans la
culture et non pas dans la sculpture
cette fois ci on va partir pour
chevreuse ou à dans les prochaines
semaines un musée dédié à l'art
contemporain va ouvrir le musée
grataloup du nom de l'artiste peintre
qui avait installé ses ateliers en 1988
décédé en janvier de cette année est ce
lieu va permettre de continuer à faire
vivre son oeuvre le reportage de
reportage de céline charles
[Musique]
as-tu fait
grataloup il y avait déjà réalisé trois
vitraux en 2011 la chapelle du saint
prieuré saint saturnin à chevreuse va
maintenant accueillir son musée une
quinzaine d'oeuvres de l'artiste
contemporain ils seront présentés à son
ouverture on y retrouve principalement
de la peinture c'est la peinture
contemporaine et l'idée c'était en fait
de rendre la peinture contemporaine un
plat accessible à tout le monde l'idée
c'est de retrouver ici en fait toute
l'histoire enfin un des grands noms de
l'histoire de la peinture contemporaine
il y aura deux expositions par an une
systématiquement autour de l'oeuvre du
peintre grataloup des conférences des
rencontres littéraires ou encore des
ateliers de méditation ou de poésie
seront également proposées par le musée
et des professionnels première
exposition du musée ciel et terre nous
plonge dans le regard que porte
l'artiste sur le monde et la nature des
oeuvres grand format seront accompagnés
de sons et de lumières pour une
expérience multisensorielle ciel et
terre donc elle s'envole dans le ciel
en quittant la terre et la terre ici
vous la voyez elle est remplie de cette
matière elle est faite à partir en fait
de sable il utilise ici aussi bien
l'acrylique que la feuille d'or que du
sable avec de l'acrylique dessus il peut
également sur la toile de droite un peu
plus loin ici que vous voyez travailler
avec de l'encré de chine grataloup
travailler dans sa maison atelier à
quelques pas du prieuré un bâtiment à
l'architecturé typique construit par de
nice lawn en 1988 pour permettre aux
peintres de laisser libre cours à son
inspiration il était très attaché à son
village de chevreuse il était amoureux
de sa vallée depuis les 15 dernières
années de sa vie il passait pratiquement
chantant intégralement dans son atelier
à chevreuse et très fascinant de voir à
quel point cet atelier reflète ses
toiles est à la fois c'est une maison
complètement étonnante qui est dans la
nature avec un toit complètement en vert
on entend la pluie le vent et les
éléments rendre accessible à tous l'art
contemporain dans la vallée de chevreuse
c'était l'objectif que s'était fixé
l'artiste il se réalisera maintenant à
travers ses oeuvres l'ouverture du musée
est fixée au 12 mars prochain
le printemps approche souvent synonyme
de beau temps en tout cas on l'espère
l'occasion de remettre un peu le nez
dehors et puis l'occasion d'aller se
promener donc à travers ce département
des yvelines nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de parler des différentes
randonnées que vous pouvez faire dans ce
département eh bien nous avons des
nouvelles idées en tout cas mélanie en a
pour nous bienvenue en plateau quels
conseils aujourd'hui vous nous donner
sur ça cette fois je propose qu'on parte
dans le sud du département pas très long
de rambouillet à poigny la forêt plus
exactement c'est la randonnée 36 de mon
petit livre fétiche les yvelines à pied
de la fédération française de randonnée
alors c'est un départ qui commence avec
une jolie cote en forêt pour découvrir
les rochers dans gêne c'est un
incontournable du massif rambolitains
desrochers qu'on ne peut pas approcher
par contre parce qu'ils sont très
fragiles mais c'est la déception de très
courte durée parce que ce qui marque la
balade c'est la flore et des fougères
partout à perte de vue 98% de la
randonnée ce passe en forêt moi je les
fait en août il faisait pas très beau
mais alors les couleurs étaient
absolument splendide qu'on a pu voir
quelques photos justement elle est
difficile cette randonnée alors au début
ça grimpe pas mal c'est comme osez
besoin de vous mettre en jambes vous ça
tape un petit peu en plus on a fait
quelques erreurs d'orientation important
pour les a vite récupéré par entre durer
le plaisir ça n'a pas tellement là pour
se réveiller aussi pour tester son sens
de l'orientation alors là par la
difficulté de cette rando aller dans sa
particularité parce qu'une grande partie
se fait dans le sable ce qui ralentit un
peu le rythme mais ce sont ensuite des
chemins facile à pratiquer où l'on
croise aussi parfois des cavaliers
excusez-moi mélanie mais juste une
précision puisqu'on voit défiler les
photos votre portable c'est juste pour
vous guider ou sais pas ce que vous
regardez vous scrollé en même temps que
la malade j'ai moi aussi
j'ai pas le ouvrage à ces ouvrages est
d'accord j'ai pris cette courageuse
evora j'ai peur que nous soyons en train
de se creuser en même temps sur les
réseaux sociaux en même temps que les
années passent mais non j'ai mangé mon
appli qui suivait aussi à ce qu'on
faisait mais ça fume portable puis ça
lâchait ceci l'occasion de reparler de
ce petit ouvrage justement où vous
l'avez mentionné les yvelines à pied
pour ceux qui voudraient se le procurer
aussi voilà pour découvrir oui les
randonnées on trouve partout en
librairie mais cette fois sans souci et
ce livre qui annonce 3h15 de ballades
sauf si on se perd sa science par à nous
c'est quand même à peu près le temps
qu'on a mis à à randonner je suis partie
des personnes qui ont une très bonne
condition physique est donc un bon
rythme mais en général on me trouvait à
l'arrière nous on a fait le choix on
aime bien on part le matin comme ça on
se pose on déjeune c'est toujours très
agréable et là il ya plein d temps on a
pris le petit étang 9 c'est une petite
pause bien sympa pour repartir derrière
bonjour la digestion pourquoi ne mangez
pas trop c'est une randonnée d'un peu
moins de 13 km qui se termine par un
très beau panorama de l'autre côté de la
départementale 137 il ya une descente
ainsi passage sur la route sur la fin
c'est ce que moi personnellement j'ai
moins apprécié c'est le retour sur le
parking et on savoir votre conseil un
rando pour ce mois ci dans le 78 tours
est entièrement un prénom les étirements
faut bien faut bien voir mais je me sens
le spécialiste des colosses
mais c'est plutôt monde de nage et les
étirements c'est les deux mots clés pour
vous pour le sable pour le sport et
les bonnes chaussures aussi oui là sur
sa la faute bien et qui perd amateurs de
randonnées dans le département j'en ai
fait une laisse et à fontainebleau oui
aussi aussi un bel endroit à découvrir
merci beaucoup mélanie d'être venu
encore ce mois ci nous donner quelques
conseils quelques bons plans rando dans
quelques minutes on va évoquer avec vous
mathilde le salon de l'agriculture après
les annulations pour cause de covin le
département des yvelines y sera une
nouvelle fois bien représentés pour
l'instant nous allons nous intéresser au
festival odyssée en yvelines avec un
nouvel invité
[Musique]
le théâtre de sartrouville en
partenariat avec le département des
yvelines propose une nouvelle fois et
jusqu'au 19 mars de découvrir six
créations pour l'enfance et la jeunesse
bonjour sylvain maurice bonjour la
directeur du théâtre de sartrouville
avant d'évoquer la programmation de
cette année déjà un mot plus générale
sur le festival 13e rendez-vous pour
odyssey en yvelines et cela fonctionne
plutôt bien c'est le bilan que vous
faites vous avez réussi cette mission
que vous étiez fixé de faire découvrir
le théâtre aux plus jeunes
absolument on rayonne dans plus de 40
villes pour 70 lieux de représentations
sur le département avec plus de 200
représentations dont oui oui on est très
présent dans des pipelines et comment on
fait découvrir le théâtre est aux plus
jeunes justement là vous vous adressez
au très très jeunes à partir de 4 ans et
puis aux adolescents aussi alors c'est
pas tout à fait pareil ce sont des
créations spécifiques pour pour eux
justement tout à fait on a une
proposition à dire par tranche d'âge des
plus petits en tout cas pour nous les
plus petits c'est la seconde section là
les plus grands en maternelle jusqu aux
collégiens voilà et donc les six
spectacles correspondre on va dire à une
tranche d'âge et les six spectacles qui
sont proposés à travers le département
et d'ailleurs je renvoie vers le site
internet de 10 ans divine pour avoir
toutes les toutes les dates ce sont des
créations
nécessité c'est que nous sommes ce qu'on
appelle un centre dramatique national en
fait un centre de création théâtrale et
dont on a des équipes d'artistes qui
craie sur le territoire des yvelines
grâce notamment au soutien du
département mais également de la ville
de sartrouville de l'état et de la
région ile de france et donc
concret in situ
loin de sartrouville puisque le
département des études vous le savez est
un département qui est très vaste
on créé en résidence des spectacles et
donc on a aussi bien de la danse de la
musique du théâtre
dans notre proposition et on a vu
quelques images pendant que vous vous
parler du spectacle est et si tu danses
nous sommes venus à la rencontre
justement des créateurs de ce spectacle
sur une des représentations déjà ça
s'adresse aux plus jeunes à partir de 4
ans en tout il y a six spectacles est-ce
que vous avez un coup de coeur peut-être
sur cette programmation de cette année
non vraiment je les aime tous
et si tu danses est en effet très très
touchant c'est marion lévy qui en fait
la chorégraphie des quatre ans j'aime
énormément jamais dormir texte et mise
en scène de baptiste aman des huit ans
que l'histoire d'une enfant comme ça
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à dormir et qu'il
raconte est un petit peu sa vie à la
fois dans son aspect concret et sinon ce
ne serait plus fantasmatique mais tous
les spectacles sont formidables depuis
que je suis née de la vie de l'escaut
dissolution julia vidit
puisque c'est comme ça je vais faire un
opéra tout seul qui est une proposition
musicale de claire diterzi et puis pour
les collégiens en salle de classe
nicole génovèse signe bien sûr oui ok et
pour revenir un peu sur justement là
l'accueil par les par les plus jeunes
par le public est ce que ça suscite un
un entrain pour la suite aussi est-ce
que vous avez des retours en ce sens est
ce que ça se réalise ensuite
[Musique]
si on propose aux plus jeunes dès leur
plus jeune âge des spectacles de qualité
on espère qu'ils deviendront spectateurs
à la suite est d'ailleurs de façon plus
générale non seulement spectateur mais
surtout qu'ils soient sensibilisés à la
création et comment la création peut
ensuite les sensibiliser à la vie tout
simplement parce qu'il n'y a pas de
barrière de séparation entre le théâtre
et la vie offenser le faire ce n'est que
le miroir dont on peut espérer qu en
confrontant les plus jeunes
puissent être mieux armé par la cie
spectacle à découvrir odyssée tirer yves
in.com pour avoir toutes les dates et
tous les renseignements toutes les
précisions sur la programmation de cette
année merci d'avoir été avec nous
quelques instants et sylvain maurice
pour nous présenter donc ce travail que
vous menez avec votre théâtre de
sartrouville et avec le département des
yvelines
petite pause gastronomie à présent
déguster des produits locaux dans un
burger c'est le pari qui a été fait par
des entrepreneurs yvelinois ils ont
lancé un food truck lambourg célia gars
de son goût est allé le tester pour nous
avec justin brasier derrière la caméra
nous sommes au chemin et des etam hier à
epône ici se trouve derrière moi le
camion le foot 3 calembours et de
gérants commencent la préparation des
repas du midi
nous allons aller les voir à l'issue les
mois
[Musique]
j'ai roetheli bonjour jean sous la
houlette du coup l'un des gérants des
deux camions fuso truck donc du coup ici
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
là ça fait sept ans qu'on l'installé
iphone qu'on a commencé l'activité et ça
se passe plutôt pas mal j'ai un camion
qui est du lundi au jeudi à leroy merlin
à buchelay et pour tous les midi et le
soir tu promène dans la campagne tout
sur cette feuille 40 hier arnaud willay
menthe et touahri et ce camion là qui se
promènent davantage les midis en trip
aubergenville epône
plaisir ma parle un peu de votre carte
vous essentiellement ce sont les burgers
que vous faites
ils sont donc fait part avec des
produits locaux ce simple et aussi frais
tout à fait j'ai un boulanger qui est
menée sous les jours un boulanger de
versailles là aux délices de versailles
après les pommes de terre c'est pareil
on va avoir vu le manchois qui à la
campagne juste à côté
par rapport à notre un autre emplacement
doit faire à peu près 5 6 km pour aller
chercher nos pommes de terre la
cyberguerre d'une complètement différent
avec des produits comme le tartare de
poisson l'époux du mans d'espelette et
c'est ça réduit en plus improbable
pourquoi bah ça permet de voyager en
fait de burgers le petit suisse ont
vraiment le fromage à raclette le lard
dont les antilles un petit peu avec le
madras la volaille mariné au lait de
coco curry et pour ceux qui n'aiment pas
eh bien on peut composer soi même sont
pas regarder la version miami où vous
avez une base avec pains viande sauce
est dedans vous mettez tous les éléments
que vous voulez pour composer le burger
de votre choix vous voulez en faire
votre burger et va aller allez on y va
ah oui c'est normal hier
à plat ok je suis prêt on commence à
couper le pain encore un sac en main
et donc là je mets la sauce la science
on en met bien chaque côté oui là c'est
bon wagon
maintenant quelles sont ces mises en mai
le steak à cuire sur ce point que ça en
20 heures
[Musique]
donc on commence par quoi tout sur la
salade toujours la salle est premier
ouais toujours est un acronyme sa lettre
aux matelas maintiennent
c'est la vie
du courage une côte et y croire j'ai
doublé mentale du chef du fromage à
raclette ou sept semaines de l'ossau
iraty ça à fromage de brebis ok ben
outils pour le fromage du monde
c'est bien
c'est un
je ne sais pas
si l oit
ce fléau
facture
voilà je suis en train de finir de
l'emballer et voilà mon regard était
même une question alors qu'est-ce que
vous avez choisi vous alors y aura un
cheeseburger à madras et un miami vous
avez commandé quoi vous le burger du
jour berlin pour moi c'est espelette
parce que je le connais bien et qu'il
est délicieux les déshabituer en fait là
on travaille à côté donc le burger du
mercredi ces voix là c'est devenu
d'anthologie toutes les semaines on
vient quand je peux mercredi je viens
et si vous aussi vous voulez profiter
des burgers du foutraque lambeaux vous
pouvez retrouver à leur adresse
d'emplacements par jour sur leur site
internet
lambois point fr et on remercie célia et
justine de ne pas nous savoir ramener de
quoi manger le midi voilà l'agriculture
qui occupe une place non négligeable
dans le département des yvelines et vous
allez pouvoir le nouvelle fois le
constater lors du salon de l'agriculture
qui va se tenir porte de versailles on
va voir ça avec vous mathilde le salon
qui s apprête à rouvrir jusqu'au 6 mars
effectivement wilfried le salon de
l'agriculture revient porte de
versailles à paris il se tiendra comme
vous l'avez dit du 26 février au 6 mars
et le salon attend la venue de sept cent
mille visiteurs environ et les
producteurs et les éleveurs sont
impatients de revenir sur place le
département tiendra un stand aux côtés
des hauts-de-seine ils seront situés
dans le hall 3 si vous voulez aller les
voir avec 90 mille hectares de terres
cultivées et environ 800 exploitations
les yvelines représente le second
territoire agricole d'île de france
derrière la seine et marne il ya
plusieurs agriculteurs producteurs
yvelinois qui seront présents sur place
oui on commence par la maison en palmier
cultivateurs de fruits et légumes de
génération en génération
ils feront une dégustation de jus de
fruits maison spécialement pour
l'occasion les visiteurs pourront
également aussi découvrir les vins de la
bouche du roi à d'avron du côté de
plaisir cela fait quatre ans que trois
amis ont repris l'exploitation des
vignes avec des pratiques
écoresponsables et biologiques la ferme
de la tremblay fera goûter ses fromages
et ses produits laitiers l'apiculteur
bilan de paris situé à saint germain on
les fera découvrir son miel multiple
médaillé en 2019 par le concours des
miels de france jacques françois samuel
vous fera découvrir son savoir faire et
les plus gourmands on ne les oublie pas
pourront goûter les cookies des deux
amis versailles et pierre et steam ou
les caramels dennis est situé à buxy on
vous a pas de donner envie de manger
après le reportage sur les burger plus
le salon de l'agriculture je sais pas ce
qu'il manque ce qu'il faut de plus un
bail est due à la fois équilibrée le
burger qui apporte un peu de plaisir et
matt hill qui nous disait tout à l'heure
vous alliez à les réaliser les
reportages sur place dès l'ouverture du
salon on imagine que vous avez déjà pris
des notes vous allez faire vos courses
et tout
salon de l'agriculture qui est aussi l
occasion pour les éleveurs appui pour
les écoles aussi agricole mettre en
avant leurs animaux c'est exactement ça
wilfried olympe une vache de race
prim'holstein âgée de trois ans et demi
sera présentée par deux étudiantes
d'agroparistech qui représenteront
également la ferme de grignon
participant au trophée international de
l'enseignement agricole elles devront
passer quatre épreuves dont une pour
présenter des caractéristiques et les
avantages de la vache on les écoute
elle a des caractéristiques de la vache
folle ya des caractéristiques
morphologiques au niveau du pis
well as début ma mère est là un bassin
c'est la ligne de 2 aussi qui est prise
en compte et après aussi les aplombs de
l'animal qui sont à c'est l'orientation
des membres fois stressant et fois
réjouissons nous de se dire pourra
participer à un concours d'une telle
ampleur elles seront pas ça une
cinquantaine d'autres participants dont
sept élèves de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet qui présenteront auréole une
autre vache également de race
prim'holstein et on pourra leur
connaître à leurs bérets rouges aussi
qu'elles ont sur la tête moi je suis
curieux de savoir pourquoi elles ont
libéré on en parle juste quarantaine ça
va leur poser la question si céline
couleurs de leur établissement
ces deux yvelinoise de la bergerie
nationale qui seront aussi en lice pour
la finale nationale des meilleurs jeunes
bergers oui lauriane conseil et manon
batista ont été sélectionnés pour
représenter l'île de france elles
devront réussir un certain nombre
d'épreuves également pour devenir les
meilleurs jeune bergère de france
évaluation de l'état de santé d'une
brebis parage des onglons reconnaissance
des races ou encore triage d'un troupeau
de brebis elles seront pas ça une
trentaine de participants venant de
toute la france on les écoute très
stressée vraiment très stressée mais
hyper heureuse et et j'ai hâte mais en
même temps on est très peur quand même
un peu stressé mais plutôt confiante
parce que c'est la troisième fois que je
participe du coup j'ai envie de vraiment
prouver ce que je sais faire et pire
rencontré beaucoup de professionnels du
milieu comme elle l'a dit ça peut être
très très cool et puis ce sera donc à
suivre aussi sur notre antenne tout au
long du salon différents reportages dans
le cours du journal puisque mathilde
vous allez sur place au cas où ils
n'auraient pas encore compris ça tout ça
pour vous dire que n'oubliez pas de nous
ramener de trois petits trucs quand même
le salon de l'agriculture lui va fermer
ses portes ensuite le 6 mars et le 6
mars c'est aussi la date du départ du
paris nice la course cycliste nicolas
oui la course ce qui ce se lancera donc
de mantes la ville et surtout il ne faut
pas confondre manque la ville avec
mantes la jolie comme je le dis bien le
dire l'une c'est la jolie l'autre c'est
la ville d'accord ça vous fâchent à on
verra que vous prenez sa 13e merdy
habitants tiennent à cela parce que on
connaît bien évidemment mantes la jolie
mais moins ce manque la ville
mantes-la-ville et pourtant c'est la
plus rurale des deux elles ont toujours
été indépendante même si elles sont
collés serrés surtout quand on prend de
la hauteur et qu'on va sur ses collines
et on voit la ville d'en haut et bien
mantes la ville de mantes-la-jolie sont
parfois aussi séparé notamment par
l'autoroute a13 mais elle arrive
toujours à se retrouver à
mantes-la-ville vous avez l'église
saint-etienne de style romaine qui
datent du 10ème siècle un édifice
religieux situé au coeur du centre ville
historique une grue commerçante qui
traverse la commune de part et d'autre
mais un lieu est au coeur de l'attention
des mots devilloise et mandeville doit
écouter la vallée si vous allez papa de
la vallée vous connaissez pas moins de
la ville c'est quand même un pack super
vous pouvez vous détendre vous posez
marché on continue son parcours au sein
de demandes la ville je redis pourquoi
un tout simplement parce que le 6 mars
il ya le départ du paris nice cours ce
cycliste vous pourrez y assister et
profitez-en aussi pour découvrir la
ville oui et justement j'ai suivi les
indications de cette dame j'ai pris la
direction du parc de la vallée un
véritable poumon vert au coeur de la
ville il s'étend sur 11 hectares
traversé par la rivière de la
vaucouleurs qui forment une vallée et
qui permet d'accéder à la ville vous
parcourrez différents chemins avec des
arbres anciens aux multiples formes vous
pouvez les voir à l'image d'ailleurs et
il est ouvert tous les jours ce parc de
9 heures à 17 heures les nouvelles il
est ouvert il est il est ouvert ouvert
on enlève la liaison pour
il ya beaucoup de verdure un vous c'est
l'époque qui veut ça ya beaucoup de
pluie et donc beaucoup de vert et donc
ouverture du parc de 9 heures à 17
heures en automne hiver et de 8h à 21h
du printemps à l'été ce parc ravit
autant les habitants qui que les curieux
qui viennent d'ailleurs regardez un très
grand parc qui accueille divers
événements un parc où on peut se
promener des attractions pour les
enfants la femme pédagogique qui a été
ouverte quelques années maintenant on
peut se promener
long du cours d'eau qui traverse le parc
on peut faire même des pique niques il
ya des endroits aménagés pour ça et
plein d'activités autour du parc des
familles qui s'y plaisent qui viennent
un saut
se promenait avec les enfants qui
découvrent la nature même parce que
c'est le parti quand même en une nature
au milieu de la ville ce qui n'est pas
assez courant et qu'on ne trouve pas
forcément partout
vous est donné envie de visiter cette
commune jolie de mantes la ville de
mantes la ville fut peur ne vous trompez
pas ce sursaut nicolas et la course
cycliste 1 du paris nice qui va
s'élancer donc de mantes la ville le 6
mars et on pourra découvrir cette
commune et puis son parc aussi un plutôt
méconnue on pense souvent verdure sud du
département mais non il ya aussi des
choses à découvrir dans le nord c'est
bientôt jusqu'à conclure là vous avez vu
la ferme pédagogique mais il ya aussi
plein d'animations tout au long de
l'année qui sont organisées des
animations culturelles sportives et
loisirs et bien évidemment comme le
monsieur l'a dit vous pouvez aller
pique-niquer pique-niqué dans ce parc
c'est bientôt la fin de ce 78 tours on
va prendre quelques instants pour vous
livrer notre sélection de boîte de nuit
à présent dans les yvelines le 78 tours
parfaits partout par le département des
yvelines là c'est bixente mais rien
senti steban qui nous livre sa sélection
forcément subjective
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà pour ce top 3 signé de bixente qui
nous livre donc sa sélection en boîte de
nuit je vais chez j'allais vous poser la
question d'ailleurs j'ai entendu qu'il y
ait beaucoup de surprises commencent à
le pacha et en troisième je ne comprends
pas je ne dirais pas qui des deux m'a
dit ça mais en tout cas on va poursuivre
le débat hors antenne 78 tours
l'émission revient le mois prochain
d'ici là elle est à revoir sur le replay
sur notre site internet et applications
mobiles merci beaucoup à vous et à
bientôt
[Musique]